it is time for the uplift at eight
that's where we share stories that will
bring you some joy to your day get you
some new smile lines i need them vlad
i'm gonna give them to you tony decouple
you look good though you look good you
look good got that demo too
we all know it can be tough to be far
from the ones we love especially around
birthdays well that's also true for
famous performers take a look
so that is actor and dancer barton
copperthwaite getting surprised by his
brothers for his 30th birthday now you
may recognize him from shows like tiny
pretty things and fosse verdon
they flew into new york city from denver
to mark the occasion was all put
together by barton's girlfriend sophie
she says he didn't suspect a thing
he was kept saying that it like doesn't
feel real it doesn't feel real um and
then we all sat down to have lunch and
then we all sort of started crying it
was just like incredibly emotional he
just kept looking at us but all three of
us being like i can't i can't believe
that this is that this is happening
sophie told us the brothers are all
extremely close they even have matching
family tattoos oh i love this family
thing and i love sophie go sophie where
it said sophie and surprise planner she
is a kid that's right she's very nice
thank you vlad that was awesome